very sad and that's where we're going to
begin today because police in a chicago
suburb they are trying to unravel the
reason for a deadly attack on the town's
fourth of july parade so can't get over
that one a gunman opened fire from the
top of a building in highland park
illinois killing six people and injuring
dozens more police are holding a person
of interest they say who posted violent
videos and imagery on social media they
have also recovered the rifle allegedly
used in the shootings joining us now is
the longtime mayor of highland park
that's nancy rotoring who was leading
yesterday's parade at the time mayor
good morning i'm so sorry that you are a
member of that club nobody wants to be
in a mass shooting in your town and we
keep hearing that at first people
thought that it was fireworks or
firecrackers when they heard it take us
there what was the scene like for you
we were in the middle of a joyful
celebration having not had this parade
for two years during the pandemic it was
multi families deep along the frayed
route with a lot of folks shouting out
it was really joyful and wonderful
i
noticed the marching band racing down
the sidewalk at one point and couldn't
understand what they were doing thought
maybe they were late for a performance
and then suddenly police cars were
racing towards us and again it was like
well maybe somebody's having a heart
attack it just didn't register
that somebody was committing a mass
shooting in in my city my husband was
right there he was right in the viewing
stance um and he said it was just
measured pop pop pop pop and he said
that's when they realized after about 15
of those that it wasn't fireworks that
it was gunshots
yeah what can you tell us about the
suspect i've heard that you you've had
some connection to him in the past
i was his cub scout pack leader he was a
little boy at the time
my heart breaks for
everybody in this town i'm not sure what
happened
uh to him to compel him to commit this
kind of evil in his hometown
but we have a city that is in deep
mourning today and we are going to take
a long time to heal from all of this
so when you heard it was him mayor what
did you think i saw an interview with
his uncle who described him as a shy kid
there was no indication that he would do
this type of thing yet the imagery on
social media tells a very different
story
what's your record i think it's
important to note
my recollection of him was as a sweet
little boy um
you know
i'm i'm sorry that that we're glorifying
what he put on social media i don't want
to encourage other people to think that
this is a way to
you know lead into this kind of violence
we need to have a very real national
conversation about why we're okay with
allowing weapons of war on our streets
and why we're okay with weekly having
mass shootings
the mayors of
toledo of
dayton the mayor of buffalo
several other mayors have reached out
and none of us think this will happen in
our city and we need to ask ourselves
why this is becoming a weekly occurrence
in our nation
mayor
we have
an issue with these individuals that
are filled with rage
in our communities that are committing
domestic terrorism
what do you believe needs to be done and
given the fact as gail mentioned you you
knew this individual when he was young
but he's not alone right there are
thousands maybe millions of individuals
just like him what do we need to do to
reach these kids at a young age so they
don't commit these crimes
i think it's a couple of things first i
think we obviously need to provide
significantly greater resources
in terms of mental health health care
we've seen those scaled back
dramatically in the last few decades but
let's ask the question of why
enraged people in other civilized
nations in our world aren't committing
these crimes we know that this is a
unique american issue and that's why we
need to take necessary steps i mean all
of these weapons and these mass
shootings have been legally obtained
that should tell us that the laws are
not doing their job when you have a city
coming together to celebrate freedom and
independence you shouldn't have to come
fearing for your life that's not what
this nation is about and we need to do
something about it
mayor on the flip side we saw incredible
acts of kindness and heroism from
members of the community some of the
images were heartbreaking fathers
putting their children in dumpsters to
protect them but also people reaching
out to families and taking in kids just
to make sure that they were okay until
the police could get to them describe to
us how the community is faring this
morning
i'm sorry if you could repeat that the
train just woke up train yeah yeah
there's a train i know how it feels when
you're doing a live shot uh just right
that how the community is fair i think
you were asking how
right the community is absolutely in
mourning and the community is in shock
uh we come together and care for each
other
we will be there for each other the
outpouring of love not just from within
the community but from across the nation
has been unbelievable but let's ask why
we why we got here i am appreciative of
all that people are doing to try to
provide care but how many times do we
need to go through this drill there
literally is a handbook that was sent to
me by several mayors telling me oh this
is what you need to do in the wake of a
mass shooting
we need to have a much stronger
conversation about why these weapons of
war are still permitted in our society
mayor rotaring thank you so much we
appreciate you joining us and
collectively as a country we need to
share this pain because we are dealing
with this
on what seems like a weekly basis basis
and we appreciate you joining us